In the name of the Father, and of the Son, and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for April 23rd, on which we commemorate, the Holy and
Glorious Great Marjorie, George the Trophy Bearer.
On the 23rd of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy and Glorious Great Marjorie
for George the Victory Bearer, and of his companions Anatolios, Protoleon, Athanasios, Anglicarius.
This great and wonderful athlete of Christ was the son of a wealthy and high-ranking
Capodoshian family.
George, having lost his father at the age of ten, his mother, Polychronia, who had become
a Christian without her husband's knowledge, returned to Palestine, her homeland, and brought
up her son in the Evangelical virtues.
Handsome, intelligent, and refined in manner, George embarked on a military career at the
age of eighteen.
He pleased his superiors and was quickly promoted to the rank of Tribune in the Imperial Guard,
and then it would appear to that of Prefect.
Returning to Capodosia after a victorious campaign and passing through the region of Atalia in
Pamphilia, he freed the King's daughter, who had been left at the mercy of a dangerous
dragon, and killed the beast, with the divine strength that he was given by his faith.
Marveling at this demonstration of the strength given by Christ to his faithful ones, against
the forces of evil, the local pagans were all converted to Christianity.
At the time of the Great Persecution unleashed by Diocletian, circa the year 304, when the
Emperor had summoned all the Eastern Governors to Nicomedia to make them privy to his
decrees against the Christians.
St. George, sensing that the moment had come for him to make public confession of Christ,
gave all his goods away to the poor, freed his slaves, and went to court.
He appeared in the midst of the assembly, and reproached the sovereign for unjustly shedding
the innocent blood of Christians.
Diocletian in stupification ordered his second-in-command, Magnentius, to interrogate this insolent
young man about his faith.
George replied that it was because he believed in Christ, the true God, that he had come without
fear to reproach them.
Having recovered from his amazement, the Emperor, fearing a tumult among those present, offered
to keep honors on the saint, on condition that he sacrificed to the gods of the Empire.
George replied, Your reign will become corrupt, and will quickly disappear at no gain to you,
but those who offer a sacrifice of praise to the King of Heaven will reign with him for
all eternity.
At the sovereign's orders, the guards beat the saint on the stomach with their lances.
His blood flowed down, but at the first blows their weapons became twisted, as though
they were made of some soft material.
Christ's soldier was then thrown into prison with a heavy stone on his breast.
The next day he appeared once more before the tyrant and showed the same firmness.
They therefore tied him to a wheel, suspended over sharp instruments, so that when the wheel
was turned, the saint's body would gradually be cut to pieces.
Overcoming the pain with his overflowing love for God, Saint George unceasingly gave thanks
to God.
A voice was then heard from heaven, saying, Fear nothing, George, I am with you.
And a white clad angel, more resplendent than the sun, descended to lose him and heal
his wounds.
When he appeared, safe and sound before the emperor, two officers of the guard, Anatolios
and Protoleon, confessed Christ with loud voices.
They were beheaded at once.
The Empress Alexandra also declared herself to be a Christian, but Magnentios constrained
her to withdraw to the palace.
They then threw the saint into a ditch filled with quicklime, but like the three young men
in the Babylonian furnace, he emerged unharmed after three days, greeted by the crowd with
a cry, Great is George's God.
The emperor still remaining insensible before all these demonstration of Christ's power ordered
that the martyr be forced to walk in shoes, studded with red-hot nails.
Run, George, towards the object of your desire, said the saint, invoking the Lord's help.
And once again he presented himself whole and radiant with grace before the tyrant.
By the grace of God he also escaped a poison prepared by a sorcerer called Athanasios.
When the latter and those of his sort were still incredulous and reckoned that George was
using magical arts, he at their requests raised a dead man, who had been buried for 300 years,
the man prostrated before the saint, and declaring that he had been rested from hell at George's
prayers, he confessed Christ.
The defeated sorcerer then fell at the feet of the servant of God, and in his turn proclaimed
the true faith.
One can decent with rage, diocletian ordered that Athanasios and the resurrected man be beheaded
without delay.
Not a few of those who had come to believe in Christ as a result of Saint George's miracles
found the means to visit him in prison in order to be instructed in the truths of the gospel
or to receive the healing of their ills.
The saint had compassion on the sufferings of each of them, and even restored to life
a bull belonging to a peasant called Gliccedios, who was then arrested and beheaded without
any sort of trial.
The next day diocletian had George appear in the temple of Apollo before a fairly large
crowd, pretending that he intended to offer sacrifice, the martyr went into the temple and confronted
the idol, making the sign of the cross.
The demons that lived in the idol then confessed in terror that Christ alone is the true God,
and they escaped with a great hubbub, leaving the inert statues to fall to the ground.
The priests and the pagans then drove the saint out with loud cries, and took him back to
the palace.
Attracted by the tumult, Empress Alexandra came out and forced her way through the crowd,
crying out, God of George, come to my aid, and she fell at the saint's feet.
Unable any longer to contain his fury, the tyrant, whose heart was hardened as pharaohs
had been of old, ordered that they both be beheaded.
But, some while before the execution, Alexandra peacefully gave her soul into God's hands
in prison.
When the day arrived, Saint George went to the place of execution, followed by a large
crowd.
He gave thanks to God for his benefits and begging his help for all those who would trustingly
invoke his intercession throughout the centuries, bent his neck under the sword, and went
to carry off the trophies of eternal glory.
Carrying out the saint's desire, his servant took his precious relics back to his country,
to Lidda, the Ospolis, in Palestine, where innumerable miracles were worked in the great
church that was built in his honor.
The veneration of Saint George enjoyed enormous popularity throughout the Christian world, both
East and West.
He was chosen to be the protector of countries like Georgia and England.
Thousands of churches have been dedicated to him, and every Christian soul sees him in
the incarnation of the virtues of valor, patience in affliction, and trust in the help of grace
that Christ, the leader in battle, has enjoined on all the soldiers enrolled in his army of
devotion.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.